bonjour à tous aujourd'hui dans science
clic la matière noire
notre univers est composé de matières
les êtres vivants les planètes les
étoiles et tout ce que nous pouvons voir
dans le cosmos effet d'atomes
c'est la matière baryonique cependant
sur la densité totale de l'univers la
matière baryonique et ses atom
tout ce que nous connaissons ne
représente que 5% la quasi totalité de
l'univers est donc composé d'une énergie
et d'une masse invisible une partie de
cette masse invisible qui constitue un
quart de l'univers et la matière noire
la matière noire n'étant pas visible et
n'interagissent en presque pas avec la
matière ordinaire elle ne peut être
observée dans le cosmos que par ses
effets gravitationnels en effet la
matière noire possédant une masse elle
déforme l'espace temps ce qui entraîne
divers phénomènes par exemple la lumière
en provenance des toiles lointaine va
être déviée selon la courbure de
l'espace temps provoquant ainsi
l'observation de mirage gravitationnelle
ces mirages qui semble n'être du a aucun
objets sont des témoins de la présence
d'une masse importante est invisible
la matière noire le mouvement des
galaxies est également un indice de
cette masse invisible en effet les
galaxies spirales comme la nôtre ne
tournerait pas de la même façon si elle
n'était pas entourée d'un halo de
matière noire et les amas de galaxies ne
se déplacerait pas comme ils le font la
matière noire représente donc une
structure complexe et très étendues dans
l'univers se pose maintenant la question
de sa nature bien qu'une infime portion
de matière noire pourrait être composée
d'atomes par exemple de trous noirs ou
deux naines brunes
elle est dans sa majeure partie non
baryonique une fraction de cette matière
noire serait composé de neutrinos des
particules très répandue dans l'univers
qui n'interagissent pas avec la matière
ordinaire ce qui les rend très difficile
à détecter
cependant à part les neutrinos la nature
de la matière noire reste un mystère
on pense qu'elle est constituée de
particules encore hypothétique qui sont
prédite par certaines théories comme par
exemple le nôtre à lino issus de la
supersymétrie qui représente un très bon
candidat
cependant beaucoup de particules sont
proposés mais aucune n'a encore été
détecté ce qui place la matière noire au
coeur des recherches actuelles le
problème de la matière noire montre
ainsi que nos théories ne sont pas
complètes et que notre compréhension du
monde n'aurait peut-être qu'à ses débuts
en effet toute la matière que nous
connaissions jusqu'ici des étoiles
lointaines jusqu'aux objets les plus
familiers ne représente qu'une part
infime du cosmos
la matière noire est encore inconnue
alors qu'elle représente cinq fois plus
que tout la matière ordinaire
cependant les trois quarts de l'univers
sont encore plus mystérieux il pourrait
contenir une forme d'énergie
fondamentale à la base de l'expansion de
l'univers
c'est l'énergie noire